dear colleagues as I mentioned the West
has begun not just the military but an
information but also
an economic
aggression but they have not achieved
success in either of these areas
and they won't achieve success there
moreover the initiators of the sanctions
are punishing themselves
they provoked a growth of prices in
their own countries
closures of factories
a collapse of energy sector
they are telling their citizens that
it's it's the Russians who are to blame
and they've used
they've used different tools they tried
to
break commercial connections with our
companies
they try to impose they
they try to restrict our expert
and theft I can't name it any other way
theft of our currency Reserves
and also attacks on our infrastructure
I'd like to emphasize that all sanctions
are just a means but the objective as
the West
says and I said directly to force our
citizens to suffer
this is the humanistic approach
they are trying to destabilize our
society from inside
were not justified and were not
successful